I'll tell you how I don't measure
success in language learning and that is
in getting
you know 9 out of ten questions right on
a test or a drill because I know from
experience that
I can get some things correct on one
occasion and get them wrong the next
time so it's not really in my opinion A
good measure of success
I have said many times that
what we like to measure at link and what
school language programs should measure
is the level of activity because if we
stay active with the language we will
improve we cannot help but improve and
so at link we measure uh you know hours
of listening words read words looked up
which is links created and so we measure
the level of activity